hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and this is Tamra's never seen and today
I'm watching True Lies I actually
watched this with the NC guys about a
week ago and I was very excited I heard
a lot of wonderful things about this
Arnold Schwarzenegger isn't it Jamie Lee
Curtis is in it I love her Freaky Friday
anyone that's where she's from right
that's her claim to fame it's Freaky
Friday I heard that it was just a 90s
action classic and I feel like I have
covered a couple 90s action classics on
here and I was ready for it
I thought but I wasn't you
[Music]
you
that was the most ridiculous film I've
ever seen
I'm so glad but it was described to me
very incorrectly everyone is like it's a
90s action film and it is but it's so
much more than that the awkward just
sexuality of Jamie Lee Curtis is just
yes give it to me give it all to me I
want it all first know what I wrote is
oh hell yeah the villain from Kazaam oh
and the girls from Wayne's purple really
got those names of actors down Tamra
wait so the story of this movie is it
Arnold Schwarzenegger is a spy an action
hero spy agents sure that's what will
give him the title of but his family
doesn't know he's got a wife and a
daughter
and they're both oblivious and so that's
where the comedy comes in so he is at a
very expensive black-tie event
working like scuba dives into he's in
there he's trying to give information
and he's dancing with this woman and Tom
Arnold is just like ditch the bitch
and so it's just there's there's a lot
of quality moments Tom Arnold right
that's his name
sure is but then he's got this
unnecessary escape from this dinner
party he's there and he's walking out
he's got the info that he needs but he's
like all right I'm feeling confident
I've had a glass of champagne let's do
this the security guard is like where's
your invitation and he pulled to help
this device and it clicks the device and
a giant explosion happens and he's like
there's my invitation glass there's two
giant very scary attack dogs that are
coming after him and he's like what what
can I do what should I do in this
specific situation I know I'll take them
and I'll grab them by their heads and
I'll headbutt two dogs heads together
with just pure force
I don't know why but I will I will never
forget that shot of arnold
schwarzenegger picking up to nothing I
don't know why it tickles me so it
wouldn't tickle me if I saw it like in
any other context cuz I love dogs
obviously I don't want people don't go
home and do this but it really tickles
me in this specific country so giant
crash with all of them shooting people
it's like you could have just quietly
snuck out the back but instead we have
this incredible thing so big I'm just
gonna keep doing really stereotypically
bad impressions of Arnold Schwarzenegger
so that's just that's what we've all
gotten ourselves into here but he goes
not yet you're never but because
terrorists are really inconsiderate when
it comes to people's schedules and man
is that ever true among other things but
schedules to talk about with so I just
saw a Mission Impossible fall out and
there is literally a fight scene that
must have been the inspiration for a
fight scene in Mission Impossible fall
out there's a bathroom see that had to
have been inspired by this bathroom
scene it's incredible he literally rips
a hand dryer off of the wall King junks
a guy's head in a urinal and then
flushed it and says here
kula then they go into a chase scene and
the chase scene is so good if there's so
many unnecessary stunts he's literally
on a horse chasing this man who's on a
motorcycle through a mall and they both
get in an elevator on their respective
ways of transportation motorcycle and
horse and it's as awkward as you think
also he got the horse by punching a cop
who was on a horse that's how he
acquired the horse he eventually loses
the bad guy because the horse won't pull
a skyscraper and jump off him
skyscrapers what are you gonna do horses
am i right then he goes to the sad sad
birthday party that was supposed to be
his it's just thrown by his wife and
daughter
another great Tom quote women can't live
with him can't kill him am i right just
so relatable so to kind of patch things
over with missing the birthday party for
like the umpteenth year in a row he goes
and surprises his wife Jamie Lee Curtis
with lunch at her office he shows up and
she's talking on the phone someone named
Simon he finally finds this guy Simon
and figures out his deal which is
hilarious because there's no deal there
Simon is faking being a spy to get women
and he's got some incredible lines that
he uses he's in it for the pussy vets
get him what I've got women lined up hot
sluts - Bill Paxton is a hilarious
sniveling little scaredy-cat in this
role and he did such a good job now
Arnold is using government surveillance
to follow Heather and Simon in a chopper
in a Jabba no I stay I can't dude hey
they didn't get you know they take her
away into a government facility and they
interrogate her she says that she needs
to feel needed again that she has
achieved on him but she felt like it was
an exciting thing and so he gives her a
mission to feel needed again just keeps
getting better it is the best
transformation that you could ever even
imagine having she's so awkward and so
weird through the whole thing
and yet it's still so sensual and so
endearing and like attractive and
adorable but she goes into this room as
this prostitute
he's like dance for me and he's sitting
literally where I am at the campus she
doesn't know it's him hilarious I just
wrote the most relatable dancing ever
and then I wrote do some awkward dancing
for the episode I think will save us all
that we none of us need that then the
terrorists come in and they take both of
them away a nuclear bomb actually goes
off that is the most ridiculous part of
this entire film and then the daughter
is taken captive forgot about her
completely and then of course they
rescue the daughter it's a lovely ending
you get to see Jamie Lee Curtis and
Arnold working together as like a spy
couple and it's so it was really funny
it was my favorite Arnold role it was my
favorite Jamie Lee Curtis role it was by
far my favorite Tom Arnold role I
remember the first time I got shot out
of a cannon Natasha
no Doris you'll say oh those guys are
totally gonna die of radiation poisoning
when they're snogging in front of the
mushroom cloud yeah that was so
ridiculous everyone wasn't immediately
terrified of radiation poisoning
maybe I played too much fallout but
that's just that's what I would have
been think about 1994 action zone you
will never look at Jamie Lee Curtis the
same way after this strip dance yes
Jamie Lee Curtis
though I've always been look at a Jamie
Lee Curtis Freaky Friday unfortunate
Muslim stereotypes yeah
again 1994 action I think you may find
some of the film problematic but overall
we'll enjoy how ridiculous this film is
I think you have to watch I have to
watch like 90s films with a grain of
salt go into it knowing that there's
gonna be some things that wouldn't be a
part of film today
this was definitely full of some
problematic things like the women can't
live with them can't kill him
problematic the Muslim stereotypes
problematic so the ditch the bitch
one-liner problem
oh so that's what comedy wasn't it is so
you got it like I said you got to go and
do it the grain of salt but yeah it's
racist and pretty sexist however it's
still entertaining as hell may not be
one of Cameron's best but I still enjoy
it from time to time I can't believe
that this is was Cameron that's so funny
to me that was something that I didn't
know until after we finished watching he
really is James Garrett like Titanic
that's that's crazy to me liked it more
than Avatar I'll say that it's a police
horse
don't let Arnold punch you up your horse
thank you so much for watching this sir
this such a fun movie to watch
especially with rents if you haven't
seen this film definitely see this film
it's a blast next week I am watching the
lego movie I've seen Ninjago and I've
seen the Batman Lego but I never saw the
original I'll see you guys good
get lost dipshit
[Music]
[Applause]
you